so speaking of games with incremental
updates for their fans the division got
a little update this morning to gain
that we've all kind of implying in the
office since it came out I think I've
tapered off a little bit in the past
couple weeks cuz there's been some
interesting games coming out I'm Erin I
feel like you sort of have the greatest
handle on the division here in the
office you played the new update this
morning is that right yeah I went
through incursion mode that's the
biggest chunk of it the rest of it's
more quality of life stuff they're
dropping guaranteed high end gear from
named enemies in the dark zone and got
these loot drops in dark zone which tape
mesh to get a hold of and then just all
around they want to make sure that you
are more easily acquiring the high-end
stuff that gets your I don't your light
level up yeah that years ago they have
gears for you which are essentially like
really it's just a light level okay and
then lie to all gear or Dada yes it got
changed across the board sodium item
level took your scores on vanity items
basically so your walnut beanie doesn't
count Thomas yeah but my modern khakis
but incursion about itself was just one
room you vs. 15 waves and okay an APC
I'd quite frankly it didn't really do it
for me right how long did it take you to
complete it so it was more of it because
I was playing on my own it was more of a
factor of matchmaking into the right
group of people right I spent probably
an hour this morning or an hour and a
half just having real bad luck yeah like
matchmaking any groups of people were
either somebody would drop oh no there's
one level design flaw where if half your
team drops but one person stays behind
and dies you can't get back up and
revive them right and took some World of
Warcraft nonsense right there and then
getting kicked by some of the like
really higher end players but once all
that was out the way and I got into a
group that kind of knew what was up it
was pretty smooth sailing like they they
knew the pattern it's real
straightforward once you get it I just
involves running at the left side
planning a charge going all the way back
in the map killing everything and
repeating a bunch of times and then you
get a piece of new armor set armor yes
you do set armor
and which they're also selling now in
other places in the game so you can you
can get it from the high-end vendor in
the base it should that thing that armor
is also dropping on some high-end named
NPC is too right I haven't seen it but
it's supposed to be you're supposed to
be able to get set items from multiple
places so the incursions is a place you
can get it from its kind of like the
weekly event that you want to try to
like do because you'll get more rewards
from it but you do get a guaranteed set
item but yeah you can get it from dark
zone there's multiple sets as well it's
very Diablo to be honest and almost like
wow ish too because like if you look at
the gear score of the hard mode
incursion it's like if you did the LFR
looking for raid version of wow and then
like if you do the challenging mode
which is a really hard one it's like all
right you did the heroic version and
you're like score on this armors
actually like that much higher than the
other one so you harrowing a lot of
those you had more trouble with much
making it sounds like yeah so I tried to
do with Rob and we scrubbed it up I'll
be honest like it was pretty frustrating
just because we would have in two
different instances of matchmaking you
know one or two guys would kind of run
off on their own because we're not a
voice chat with them right and they're
like either trying to figure out how the
incursion itself works or just doing
their own thing and it's already like
pretty like intense because there's a
lot of mobs there's turds from the APC
and it's like please don't go over there
I don't I cannot revive you because
you're you're basically hamstringing us
and because there's no checkpoints it's
very punishing you can get four to five
waves in and if somebody just goes wild
card rogue or something would you have
to do once you've beaten four or five
waves yeah exactly and then like it just
use just a great we're gonna start all
over and it's just like super freshing
socially throws a curveball in weight
fifteen to where you go to arm the same
way you've armed every other time and a
wave of guys come out right up a point
on top of it rise which it doesn't do at
any other point and so you could
potentially get really frustrated
because you got all the way to 15 and
then the game just screwed you over time
what was the 15 the max with a lot
between waves on hard i didn't go to
challenging mode yet 15 still the same
yeah it's just in challenging versus
hard which it is right now you just have
more elite so basically they're higher
level have more life and stuff cool what
are the changes have happened that side
of that i guess that's out of incursion
just a quick note
tay tay looked at the top of the map and
you saw that they actually have a
placeholder for the next dlc already too
oh that one's i think it's free update
as well as this one so that the next
incursion is just at the top of the map
it's called like I think broken circle
or something is like hey there's here's
the next one here's how much gear score
you need and yeah it'll be in the next
free update we have any idea when that's
coming no like probably pre III I don't
yeah well so I think the big deal sees
June ok so don't you mean maybe yeah but
to get back to your point yeah well yeah
what are sort of stuff for for the chair
know the more I don't know I play
destiny like or psychotic Donna yeah I
think I know right HD I love that d I
can't remember one and which division
are i plated division like very slow
methodical sort of solo we kind of way
which is probably not the right way to
play this game is there anything though
that they've changed in terms of just
the general play of the game oh yeah so
for someone especially like yourself if
you've been soloing anyone that has
soloed knows how much slower it is and
just how much longer it takes you to get
through stuff yeah get your dark zone
level of and whatnot so now they've kind
of like Aaron said quality of life a lot
of quality of life stuff it's look they
lowered a lot of the dark zone rankings
so that you could buy stuff faster so
that you know you didn't have to grind
so far to get stuff also there's almost
half yeah it's almost like half and then
like 32 15 and whatnot but uh there's
also like trading so like if you do play
with a friend and he's like hey like I
I'm pretty geared out Danny like have
all these other high ends that I don't
need and you ride like gear up faster
okay and so they stalk someone
specifically no you can do that in lucca
open open world as well dark zone you do
either have to extract it and then trade
it or go into a like checkpoint and then
traded they don't want you to tre like
Mitch middle the area just have so much
okay thanks for the loop guys I know so
that those are in there and then also
just the biggest one really is high ends
will guarantee drop off named bosses now
so you know when you kill something
you're gonna get something good okay so
people must have got real pissed about
thought if they've just decided okay one
hundred percent drop right no I think I
think it's actual it's hard to say like
from a hardcore perspective maybe you're
a little salty from all the time you
spent farming up till now yeah
but it's it helps casual to like medium
hardcore players because now you feel
like your times yeah I've worked really
frustrating yeah they also they wanted
to fundamentally change the way that
people were playing this game it was one
of those things where they were
motivating people to basically just
scrap items the entire game yet so they
got to the end game and then craft the
one vector like 20 times in a row until
he had the perfect role is one of those
things where like we saw with the lead
cave in and destiny the developers just
saying we had not intended people to
play the game this way riya we wanted a
more even split of people getting lewd
off killing bosses off of vendors and
off of crafting they didn't want to see
this spike where everybody was just
sacrificing the game to craft because it
wasn't necessarily fun for a lot of
players who didn't want to just do loot
runs around the dark zone so it's there
it's their way of rebalancing out the
loot system so that it's more rewarding
for a variety of players yeah yeah so
Justin I know to just in this patch as
well or update it is more expensive to
craft now but because you are getting so
many more high-end drops at a more
frequent pace you should be able to even
itself out yeah but it's again a very
Diablo thing where you know they saw
that by increasing the amount of drops
players are having more fun right like
there's so much variance in these drops
to begin with that like everyone's
trying two min max at the end of the day
really trying to get a perfect role but
for a lot of people it's just like oh
yeah I got a yellow like yeah that's
another high getting the the high end
and that's what they did with this and
makes people happy right that's what
they're offsetting it by making the
armor very specific though and its stats
so you'll only really become more
powerful if you have armor of the same
type right and then you'll become really
good at one thing but you'll actually
probably be weak at another thing so
it's four different armor paths that
gets you really good at four different
things so it's a way to elongate the the
grind everyone than the chasch although
fighting between destiny division also
commenting on how lovely your hat is it
was that your house in the gameplay I
did not have
yeah you didn't have a hat was
definitely raza Rob yeah it's got a
great hot trapper hat yeah we'll talk to
Robert has hot in a minute and we're
gonna get him on in a second to talk
about retching client before I let you
guys go um if he right now which game
are you playing at I know it's making
these binary things is always very silly
but like if you're what's again you're
going back to at the moment as fans of
both the division and destiny which is
the one Eric that you're playing at the
Molitor Dark Souls 3 now sorry there the
other day third day yeah exactly oh man
it's really hard for me um I almost have
to gravitate more towards whoever i know
is playing the game right yeah is this a
social thing right like and you for me
my the amount of fun i have playing with
like Rob we're like Chris or someone
like it implies that right so that will
definitely influenced my decision I
would say the pc answer for me is I'm
splitting 5050 the best I can okay but I
can understand why division most people
gravitate to because it's anywhere
there's s stuff you don't understand but
like you're right that's like them such
a big part of these games that you know
trying to make sure that their fan base
is their player bases are satiated is
because the one of the main reasons you
play these games because of your friends
I mean like every kid look at ever get
look at overwatch with us in the officer
or even rocket Lee lucky there's like a
threshold you reach past and once you're
past there I feel like people just are
easier of playing that game because
there's like a group of people playing
it a lot of what about yourself our
destiny is more punishing though to you
as an individual player if your friends
aren't there yes rare sure division does
for better or worse I've matchmaking in
the vast majority of its activities even
the dark zone you can matchmaking I you
don't you might get a crappy partner but
well your guess yeah that's literally
why I just could not hang on to destiny
and the division is sort of retained me
a little bit more yeah you can you can
solo it much you can you cancel it more
in a more fun manner mmm it's more
friendly to you that's the game I'm
gonna stick with just because it's a
newer of the two and destiny again have
this office for a full year and I think
it's time to hang that up until they
have something like actual actually
significant and if they ever want to get
around to actually telling us the story
of destiny like the traveler which was
the entire thing and the stranger which
was
entire thing in more than just like oh
here's a bad dude and here's his bad
daddy like hmm yeah cool once you once
you want to tell me that story I'd be
happy to go back and speak again
speaking of which we're gonna get the
guys on [ __ ] about time falls well let's
let's get those jerks in there at while
we're doing that the vork 67 says
tailored your double Dean yeah I am I'm
a triple Dean technically because Dark
Souls Souls and I hablo you've always
got to da blows your babe got on it i'm
here i haven't played that in a while
but yeah i developed our wants the wall
who'da thought actually I didn't really
think before Dean my hand you let it out
of places to play them all I know right